[Musik]
Homöopathie Wirkung ist was du draus
machst
[Applaus]
[Musik]
danke schön hallo und herzlich
willkommen zum meist things ich die Show
Folge 13 die glücksendung nach der
Sommerpause und habt ihr Bock auf
Wissenschaft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hat richtig Bock und wir geben uns bei
Maite x natürlich immer größte Mühe aber
ich glaube heute muss ich uns einfach
mal selbst loben heute wird es wirklich
super gut super interessant und super
unterhaltsam also zumindest für Freunde
der Wissenschaft nicht zu unterhaltsam
wird für Freunde von Homöopathie die
werden notre-news sein denn heute
zerstören wir die Homöopathie
Zeit
ich spüre schon nervöse Schwingungen von
da draußen hier im Studio freuen sich
einige schon andere schauen noch
skeptisch entweder weil sie sich als
Homöopathie Fans in der
wissenschaftssend
ja ja schon wieder eine Sendung über
Homöopathie also ich habe grob
überschlagen schon tausendmal erklärt
wieso Homöopathie nicht wirken kann und
wie oft habe ich knallharte Homöopathie
Fans damit überzeugen können ziemlich
genau null mal nee so wird das nichts
das ist mir inzwischen klar deswegen
machen wir heute alles ganz anders aber
einfach am anderen während der
Sommerpause ist viel passiert wir waren
sehr fleißig und ich werde versuchen
euch alles in dieser kurzen halben
Stunde zu erzielen fangen wir vorne an
während ihr im Sommerurlaub schön am
Strand gelegen und Sonnenenergie getankt
habt hatten wir eine geniale Idee
einen Eistee produzieren der nicht mit
Zucker gesüßt ist sondern mit Globuli
und damit nicht nur zeigen dass da
wirklich nichts als Zucker drin ist
sondern den Eistee natürlich auch für
einen normalen Eistee Preis verkaufen
damit würde man ja Globuli für einen
Bruchteil von dem Preis bekommen den man
sonst in der Apotheke zahlen würde
Homöopathie mal nicht durch Aufklärung
sondern wirtschaftlich vom Markt
verdrängen
aber zunächst gab es ein paar
Startprobleme
also Leute was der stand
also wir haben einen Namen Homöopathie
[Applaus]
wir haben auch schon Abfüller gefunden
das Problem ist nur wir müssen
mindestens 5000 Flaschen bestellen also
wie viele Flaschen Eistee könnt ihr
trinken 25 pro Woche pro Tag aber wenn
wir 25 Gramm Globuli pro Flasche
brauchen bei 5000 Flaschen
wisst ihr was das kostet vielleicht
können wir sie ja verkaufen und so den
Verlusten minimieren
[Musik]
das ZDF hatte ein paar Probleme mit
unserem Businessplan Globuli für
Gebührengelder teuer einkaufen und
billiger verkaufen okay kann man
verstehen vor dem rbb Skandal wäre das
vielleicht noch gegangen aber jetzt
schwierig aber nicht unmöglich man muss
ja immer nur ein Stockwerk höher gehen
bis man jemanden findet der ja sagt aber
das dauert und während wir auf einer
Entscheidung gewartet haben hatte ich
eine Idee was sage ich eine Erleuchtung
pass auf die Beliebtheit von Homöopathie
hält sich ja unerschütterlich in
Deutschland wird jährlich über eine
halbe Milliarde Euro für homöopatika
ausgegeben und auch in der Politik gibt
es viele Fans Manfred luchert zum
Beispiel baden-württembergischer
Gesundheitsminister von den Grünen
kämpft dafür die Homöopathie
Weiterbildung für Ärzte vorzuführen
obwohl die Landesärztekammer dagegen ist
Tanja Schorer Dremel von der CSU sagte
im Bayerischen Landtag sie habe drei
Kinder mit Homöopathie großgezogen und
sie sind alle pump-pal gesund
und Christian lange ehemaliger
spd-staatssekretär im Bundesministerium
für Justiz und Verbraucherschutz sagt
Homöopathie gehört zu einer guten
Patientenversorgung darin war ich mir
mit der Geschäftsführung der Weleda
einig
Homöopathie ist nicht irgendein Nischen
Esoterik Ding Homöopathie gehört zum
Mitte der Gesellschaft wie auch zur
Mitte der Politik ich meine Globuli und
andere homöopathiker gelten vor dem
deutschen Arzneimittelgesetz ganz
offiziell als Arzneimittel viel
offizieller geht's nicht so lange
Homöopathie von unserem Gesetzgeber
ernst genommen wird darf ich mich ja
nicht drüber wundern dass sie auch von
vielen Anwenderinnen ernst genommen wird
das ist die erste Einsicht die zweite
Einsicht geht aber viel tiefer warum
konnte ich bisher noch nie einen echten
Homöopathie werden überzeugen weil
wir komplett verschiedene Sprachen
sprechen ich argumentiere mit
Wissenschaft Homöopathen argumentieren
mit Dingen die über Wissenschaft
hinausgehen und so drehen wir uns für
immer in Kreis nee das bringt nichts mir
wurde klar wenn ich den Feind zerstören
will muss ich lernen wie der Feind zu
denken also lass mich das noch mal
anders formulieren wenn man eine
konstruktive Diskussion führen will
muss man sich in den anderen reindenken
können mal die Perspektive wechseln
richtig das alles einfach viel zu
chemisch
reinstofflich betrachtet bestehen
Globuli nur aus Zucker ja aber die
Wirkung ist nicht stofflich Moleküle
müssen gar nicht anwesend sein um die
Wirkung zu haben scheiß auf Chemie
mai alles in Ordnung mit dir nie besser
das Grundprinzip von Homöopathie ist ja
Ähnliches mit Ähnlichem bekämpfen das
heißt Globuli lösen bei Gesunden die
Symptome aus gegen die sie bei
krankenhelfen ja mal das wissen wir
schon zum Beispiel Safran Globuli führen
zu
kommt mit dem Penis
deswegen helfen Safran Globuli bei Penis
jucken aber nur wenn man auch trockene
Augen und große Lust hat zu tanzen und
sich schnell beleidigt fühlt was hast du
gerade zu mir gesagt
[Musik]
genau
nur damit das klar ist das mit der
Tanzlust und dem juckenden Penis nach
Satan Globuli das haben uns nicht
ausgedacht das ist das Ergebnis der
homöopathischen Arzneimittelprüfung da
geht man gesunden Menschen Globuli und
die schreiben dann wochenlang sehr genau
auf was sie alles an sich feststellen
also Kopfschmerzen trockene Augen
Müdigkeit seltsame Träume gute Laune
schlechte Laune juckender Schritt was
auch immer die Symptome sind genau
dagegen können diese Globuli dann bei
Kranken helfen Ähnliches mit Ähnlichem
behandeln deswegen ist am besten bei
Beschwerden erstmal ein zwei Stunden mit
seinem Homöopathen zu reden denn wenn
ich jetzt Globuli gegen Müdigkeit haben
will krieg ich nicht irgendein
pauschales Anti müdigkeitskügelchen der
homöopat schaut dann erstmal in seine
symptomlisten ist da auch Verstopfung
und Tanzfluss dabei dann eher Safran
Globuli oder sind es doch eher
Rückenschmerzen und Vergesslichkeit dann
sind es eher Arnika Globuli also
Homöopathie ist ganzheitlich und in
jetzt müssen wir nur noch verstehen wie
genau Globuli wirken und das erklärt
euch jetzt Tatjana Gertz
[Applaus]
echt sehr schön
[Musik]
also
was machst du hier gerade also ich
stelle eine der meist gekauften Globuli
her Annika D12 Annika also so eine gelbe
bergblume ja genauer gesagt Arnika
Extrakt eine D12 Potenz bedeutet dass
ich das Extrakt 12 mal im Verhältnis 1
zu 10 verdünnt habe ja in diesem Liter
D12 sind dann nur noch
0,000000
ein Gramm Arnika drin das ist wenig ja
aber hiervon sprüht man dann 0,1 ml auf
10 Gramm Zuckerkügelchen so das machen
wir mal ganz kurz
ja und jetzt sobald also sobald das
alles trocken ist dann tut man das dann
da rein in die kleine Globuli flächler
das war's ja und man nimmt es dann zum
Beispiel gegen alle möglichen Arten von
Prellungen und Stoßverletzungen also
Quetschungen Blutergüsse Muskelkater
aber auch bei Rheuma Gehirnerschütterung
Hirnschlag das muss man dann alles in
seinem mit seinem Homöopathen in einem
ausführlichen Anamnesegespräch
ganzheitlich und individuell besprechen
warum erzählen wir diesen Quatsch hier
erzählen Quatsch wir erzählen wie
Globuli funktionieren wir nehmen das
ernst wir glauben daran scheiß auf
Chemie okay alles klar ja was soll ich
als nächstes herstellen wie wäre es mit
Safran C30 wie bei unserem Eistee
30 also 10 Potenz 1 zu 100 statt 1 zu 10
alles klar
gut so jetzt kommt die nichtstoffliche
Erklärung das Globuli wirken obwohl ab
einer bestimmten Potenz gar kein
Wirkstoff mehr vorhanden ist liegt am
Gedächtnis des Wassers das Wasser
erinnert sich an den Wirkstoff ja und
gibt diese Erinnerung an den Körper
weiter also chemisch oder physikalisch
betrachtet gibt es zwar keine plausible
Erklärung für so ein wassergedächtnis
aber in der Wissenschaft kann man
schließlich nicht alles erklären wir
wissen halt nicht wie wir wissen nur
dass es wirkt deshalb das
allerwichtigste bei der Herstellung
darüber haben wir noch gar nicht
gesprochen das kommt jetzt ja genau das
Schütteln bei jedem Verdünnungsschritt
muss ich die Lösung zehnmal auf ein
harten aber nicht nur hart sondern
elastischen Untergrund aufschlagen so
wie das hier so
durch dieses schütteln erhält die Lösung
genauer gesagt das Wasser da drin sein
Gedächtnis durch dieses aufschlagen kann
sich das Wasser später auch noch an den
Safran erinnern selbst wenn kein
einziges Molekül mehr anwesend so jetzt
sind wir bei 10 jetzt ist erst die
Potenz fertig genau Potenz wir sprechen
nicht von verdünnen sondern von
potenzieren genau und dann ja für die
nächste Potenz nehme ich hier wieder was
raus fülle es auf und schlage es wieder
zehnmal auf genau hier höher die Potenz
also je öfter man das macht desto größer
die Wirkung eine C30 Lösung wurde also
30 Mal verdünnt und 300 Mal geschüttelt
und hat sich dabei ganz viele Dinge
gemerkt das heißt gerade die hoch
potenzierten Globuli Update 30 aufwärts
oder die C-Potenzen wo stofflich
wirklich kein Wirkstoff mehr drin ist
die sind besonders stark in Thema
Wirkung und was passiert dann mit dem
Rest von der letzten Potenz ja der kommt
weg sonst hätte ich ja irgendwann
Swimmingpools voller Wasser hier rum
stehen
potenzierte Pools danke katjana
[Applaus]
also die alte Maja die hat jetzt fragen
gehabt zum Beispiel wie sich die
Zuckerkügelchen an irgendwas erinnern
sollen wenn doch das Gedächtnis im
Wasser liegt dass er beim Trocknen
komplett verdampft
aber die neue mai die weiß dass man
nicht alles verstehen muss
hauptsache wir wissen dass es Dir nicht
wie es wirkt ist jetzt auch erstmal
sekundär ja dann hat das Wasser halten
Gedächtnis
das ist die Basis von Homöopathie und
ihrer Wirkung potenziertes Wasser
Leute bei der Herstellung von Globuli
fällt durch das ganze verdünnen ja sehr
viel Wasser als Nebenprodukt an
potenziertes Wasser Gedicht ist
kontaminiert die Frage ist
holen wir dieses Wasser gekippt doch
hoffentlich nicht in den Abfluss
naja noch allgemein geltenden
laborregeln darf man ab einer gewissen
Potenz natürlich alles in den Abfluss
kippen ist ja dann nur noch Wasser nur
Wasser die Wissenschaft mal wieder naja
wenn wir davon ausgehen
das war sein Gedächtnis hätte hat Wasser
hat ein Gedächtnis
wie andere Arzneimittel auch als
Sondermüll entsorgen ist halt deutlich
aufwendiger und teurer ja klar machen
die das die werden es doch nicht einfach
so in den Abfluss kippen ich meine ganz
ehrlich wir leben hier in Deutschland
hier ist sogar geregelt dass du einfach
so fremde Grundstücke betreten darfst
also wenn du deinen Bienenschwarm
verfolgst
okay ich frage immer nach ja das hat
Hanna dann auch gemacht denn Homöopathie
wirkt weil potenziertes Wasser ein
Gedächtnis hat dann muss es ja auch
Regelungen für potenzielles Abwasser
geben solche Regelungen gibt es für
andere apothekenpflichtige Arzneien
schließlich auch zuerst hat Hanna beim
Umweltbundesamt nachgefragt und die
haben uns an die Wasserbehörden der
Städte verwiesen in denen homöopathische
Arzneimittel hergestellt werden und auch
da haben wir dann nachgefragt Karlsruhe
Baden-Baden und Bad Kreuznach alle
Städte in denen Homöopathie Hersteller
ansässig sind aus Bad Kreuznach kam gar
nichts aber die Stadt Baden-Baden
schrieb uns in unserem Fall gäbe es
Zitat keine speziellen wasserrechtlichen
Anforderungen keine speziellen
Anforderungen man kann auch nicht
potenziertes Wasser voller Gedächtnis
und Wirkung behandeln als wäre es
stinknormales Brunnenwasser spinnen die
die Stadt Karlsruhe schrieb uns das
Abwasser wird zusammen mit den anderen
abwasserströmen in der Kläranlage der
Stadt Karlsruhe über eine vierte
Reinigungsstufe in Klammern Aktivkohle
geleitet ja schon klar Aktivkohle kann
medikamentenreste binden das weiß ja
jede Chemikerin aber da geht es ja um
eine stoffliche Ebene wir sprechen von
potenziertem Wasser da ist ja bei hohen
Potenzen eh kein einziges Molekül von
irgendwas drin das an Aktivkohle hängen
bleiben könnte aber dafür hat das Wasser
umso mehr Gedächtnis wir konnten noch
nirgendwo Hinweise darauf finden ob und
wenn ja wie sich dieses wassergedächtnis
löschen lässt also alle
abwasservorschriften sind komplett auf
eine Welt ausgelegt in der Stoffe auch
anwesend sein müssen um zu wirken für
Homöopathie die nichtstofflich wirkt
gibt es keine extra regeln krass dabei
geht's doch Studien in hoch angesehenen
homöopathiezeitschriften
die die Auswirkungen von Gedächtnis
kontaminierten Wasser auf die Umwelt
nachweisen diese Studie zum Beispiel
zeigt dass die Metamorphose von
besonders geschützten grasfröschen durch
gedächtniswasser gehemmt wird und diese
Studie zeigt ein Effekt aufs Wachstum
der ökologisch wichtigen Wasserlinse
klar die alte mai hätte gesagt dass
diese Studien methodisch nicht sagen
sind gibst du überhaupt eine
Kontrollgruppe war das statistisch
signifikant aber jetzt wo ich die
Wirkung ernst nehme
besorgt mich das alles doch sehr selbst
selbst Samuel Hahnemann der Erfinder der
Homöopathie hat ausdrücklich gewarnt das
Überdosierung sogar tödlich sein könnte
und warte davor homöopathische Tinkturen
oh Gott ich bin schon so aufgeregt
homöopathische Tinkturen beim Transport
nicht aus Versehen zu schütteln das
Gedächtnis und die Wirkung
könnte sonst zu stark werden doch das
potenzierte Abwasser
das wird in den Rohren durchgeschüttelt
im Klärwerk wird es nochmal geschüttelt
von da geht es in die Flüsse und die
Bäche wilder durchgeschüttelt und am
Ende landet das alles als sauberes
Trinkwasser in unseren Wasserhähnen
extrem verdünnt extrem oft geschüttelt
das entspricht einer extrem hohen Potenz
und DHU einer der größten Hersteller von
homöopatica in Deutschland sagt selbst
hohe Potenzen sollten immer von einem
Arzt oder Heilpraktiker ausgewählt
werden und nicht einfach aus dem
Wasserhahn gezappt
ach du scheiße ne das nimmt ja Ausmaße
an die kann man gar nicht kontrollieren
leute Leute
das ist so kleiner die grasfroschation
[Applaus]
ganz ruhig ganz ruhig wahrscheinlich
haben wir irgendwas über sie ne irgendwo
gibt's bestimmt einen Missverständnis
oder man kann das Gedächtnis doch
löschen oder so das ist doch bestimmt
irgendwie geregelt wir haben bei der
Carsten Stiftung nachgefragt einer
Stiftung zur Förderung der Erforschung
von Homöopathie außerdem bei deutschen
zentralverein homöopathischer Ärzte bei
der wissenschaftlichen Gesellschaft für
Homöopathie und auch bei einigen anderen
und die haben uns das geantwortet
nichts
gut die Karsten Stiftung hat uns nur an
die Hersteller verwiesen gute Idee
deshalb haben wir bei den größten
Herstellern des Landes nachgefragt bei
heel Hevert und auch bei DHU und die
haben das geantwortet
auch nix Herr gut ein Hersteller ein
Hersteller hat geantwortet und zwar
Hevert wir können Ihre Anfrage aufgrund
aktueller Krankenstände verbunden mit
der Urlaubszeit leider nicht beantworten
ich sag mal so ne die alte mai die
zynische mal die hält jetzt gefragt wie
es kommen kann dass bei einem Hersteller
von Arzneimitteln so viele Leute krank
sind
aber die neue mal die Homöopathie
wirklich ernst nehmen will die
tröstet sich einfach mit pauschalen
Aussagen wie dieser von der Website der
Karsten Stiftung die Homöopathie ist
insgesamt als nebenwirkungsarmes
Therapieverfahren einzustufen hier
widerspricht die Stiftung sogar Samuel
Hahnemann und der sich den ganzen Bums
immerhin ausgedacht also ich muss
ehrlich gestehen an dem Punkt hat meine
gerade erst frisch entflammte Liebe für
die Homöopathie doch schon ein paar
erste kleine Risse bekommen
wenn der Gesetzgeber zwar einerseits so
sehr an die Wirkung glaubt dass man das
Zeug nur in der Apotheke verkaufen darf
ist aber andererseits völlig okay findet
wenn potenziertes Wasser die Basis von
Homöopathie einfach weggekippt wird also
ich weiß nicht irgendwie war das eine
Sackgasse und dann ist mir wieder unser
Eistee eingefallen
wenn man ein normales Eis hier Rezept
nimmt und den Zucker mit Safran C30
Globuli ersetzt oder wie es korrekt
heißt Krokus C30 dann sind da pro
Flasche knapp 25 Gramm Globuli drin es
kann ja nicht sein das ist gar keine
Sicherheitsregeln bei homöopathiker gibt
wenn schon das Abwasser offenbar
niemanden interessiert wird auch
wenigstens die Bevölkerung davor
geschützt werden wenn keine Ahnung zum
Beispiel eine kleine ZDFneo
wissenschaftshow in großen Stil so ein
Eistee herstellt und an der
Apothekenpflicht vorbei einfach in
Supermärkten Kiosken und Getränkemärkten
verkauft hypothetisch hypot wir haben
auch für diesen hypothetischen Fall mal
nachgefragt zum Beispiel beim b-farm dem
Bundesinstitut für Arzneimittel und
Medizinprodukte die müssen das Wissen
dachten wir aber die haben uns zur
Bezirksregierung Köln weitergeleitet
weil wir in Köln produzieren wollten und
die wiederum haben uns zurück zum
b-farben geschickt weil sie dafür gar
nicht zuständig sein und so ging das
insgesamt zehn mal hin und her zwischen
dem b-formen der Bezirksregierung und
uns bis es mir zu blöd wurde dann habe
ich Karl Lauterbach angerufen
habe ich nicht habe ich nicht wir haben
eine ganz normale eine Anfrage ans
Bundesgesundheitsministerium geschickt
per Mail in der Mail haben wir genauer
gesagt für zwei Fälle angefragt Fall 1
dürfen wir einen Eistee der mit in eine
Apotheke gekauften Krokus C30 Globuli
gesüßt wurde als Lebensmittel verkaufen
und Fall 2 ich lese vor
wir haben das Gewürz Safran in einem
Lebensmittelgeschäft gekauft und daraus
ein Extrakt hergestellt dieses Extrakt
haben wir 30 Mal im Verhältnis 1 zu 100
verdünnt nach jedem Verdünnungsschritt
wurde die Lösung jeweils zehnmal auf
einen weichen Untergrund aufgeschlagen
nach 30 Wiederholungen wurde dieser
höchst verdünne Lösung auf
Zuckerkügelchen aufgetragen nach dem
Trocknen der Kügelchen wurden diese dann
verwendet um Eistee zu süßen dürfen wir
diesen Eistee als Lebensmittel verkaufen
und nur noch mal zum Verständnis ne also
Vereins und falls zwei sind genau das
gleiche das ist der gleiche Eistee mit
den gleichen Globuli würde eine Apotheke
rin die Globuli genauso herstellen wie
in der Mail beschrieben dürfte sie das
am Ende als Krokus C30 Globuli in der
Apotheke verkaufen
die Antwort vom
Bundesgesundheitsministerium war
der hier beschriebene Eistee dürfte als
Lebensmittel zu qualifizieren sein und
unterfällt den lebensmittelrechtlichen
Vorschriften gegen den Konsum solcher
Produkte sollte es grundsätzlich keine
rechtlichen Bedenken geben moment mal
Lebensmittel rechtliche Vorschriften so
das denn Karl das sind
apothekenpflichtige Arzneimittel drin
aber die Antwort geht noch weiter ob das
Lebensmittel in den beschriebenen
Zusammensetzungen verkehrsfähig ist
obliegt der Einschätzung der zuständigen
Behörde und diese zuständige Behörde ist
das b-farm oder die Bezirksregierung
Köln oder das Bevern die beiden streiten
immer noch wer von beiden damit weniger
zu tun haben möchte
die Bezirksregierung hat am Ende noch
auf eine dritte Behörde verwiesen das
Landesamt für Natur Umwelt und
Verbraucherschutz in NRW und weil wir eh
gerade dabei waren haben wir auch da mal
nachgefragt und parallel noch mal bei
Karl Lauterbach ob diese Antwort jetzt
für beide Eistee Varianten gilt die
Antworten kam fast zeitgleich ich weiß
ihr könnt die Spannung kaum aushalten
das Gesundheitsministerium schrieb ja in
beiden Fällen dürfte das Produkt als
Lebensmittel zu qualifizieren sein eine
Cola die Koffein enthält oder ein Tonic
Water das Chinin enthält sind ja auch
keine Arzneimittel also
als ich
als ich zuletzt nachgesehen habe
war in Cola ja auch keine
apothekenpflichtige Menge Koffein in
unserem Eistee sind zweieinhalb
Fläschchen Globuli drin
das ist 600 Mal die empfohlene Dosis
aber gut es blieb ja noch das Landesamt
für Verbraucherschutz meine letzte
Hoffnung das Homöopathie wirklich von
Staat und Gesetz als Arzneimittel ernst
genommen und konsequent als solches
behandelt wird und die haben geschrieben
Kokos C30 ist ein homöopathisches
Arzneimittel eine Verwendung dieses
Arzneimittels ist als Zutat in
Lebensmitteln nicht zulässig Halleluja
endlich danke
endlich eine konkrete Aussage ein
Arzneimittel dass ich nicht einfach in
mich reinschütten darf also die Mail
ging auch noch weiter im zweiten
beschriebenen Fall Ihre Anfrage werden
für die Herstellung des Eistees unter
anderem Safran und Haushaltszucker
verwendet sofern der hergestellte Eistee
die lebensmittelrechtlichen
Anforderungen erfüllt kann dieser in den
Verkehr gebracht werden
ich übersetze das mal wenn ich als
Apothekerin Globuli nach allen Regeln
des Arzneibuches herstelle Fall 2 darf
ich sie in Eistee tun und als
Lebensmittel verkaufen ich kann
dieselben Globuli aber auch als
Arzneimittel verkaufen dann natürlich
nur in meiner Apotheke und wenn man die
dann kauft Fall 1 darf man sie nicht in
Eistee tun und das Lebensmittel
verkaufen
also ganz ehrlich Leute das hier
das ist lächerlich
entweder Homöopathie wirkt und dann
sollte man sie wie jedes andere
Arzneimittel auch nicht einfach random
nehmen dann müssen sie
apothekenpflichtig sein dann dürfen sie
aber natürlich auch nicht einfach in die
Umwelt gelangen und natürlich darf man
damit dann auch keinen Eistee süßen oder
sie wirkt eben nicht
dann dürfen homöopathische Mittel aber
auch nicht als Arzneimittel in der
Apotheke verkauft werden und Herr Lange
das ist ja schön dass Sie sich mit der
Geschäftsführung der Weleda einig sind
sie wissen schon wer leder ist ein
Hersteller von homöopathischen Mitteln
also die nach ihrer Meinung zur
Homöopathie zu fragen ist ein bisschen
wie Lord Voldemort zu fragen wie es mit
dem dunklen Künsten hält
ich nicht ärger mich natürlich auch so
ein bisschen denn nach allem was wir
inzwischen wissen hätten wir den Eissee
auch einfach produzieren können
und das haben wir natürlich auch gemacht
falls ihr euch fragt auf jeden Fall
kriegt jeder von euch eine Flasche ja
danke schön leider groß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ganz ruhig ganz ruhig ne bitte ruhig
bleiben jeder kriegt eine Flasche ne und
wenn ihr nach dem Trinken Bock habt zu
tanzen oder euer Penis juckt bitte
schreib uns bei Twitter oder Instagram
#metinkix und ihr zu Hause könnt den
Homöopathie natürlich auch probieren ihr
bekommt unseren Eistee ab morgen
Tankstellen und wenn er nicht vorrätig
sein sollte ja fragt einfach danach und
wenn ihr Homöopathie Fans im
Freundeskreis oder in der Familie habt
schreibt in eure whatsapp-gruppen
Homöopathie statt Homöopathie
[Applaus]
denn mit 25 Gramm Zucker pro Flasche pro
Flasche das entspricht fast 3000 Globuli
für den Bruchteil des Kreises und dann
schickt ihn den Link zu unserer Website
jetzt bestellt unter Wirkung ist was du
draus machst de
so jetzt wir sammeln uns alle noch mal
wir sind noch nicht fertig um uns
rechtlich abzusichern haben wir ein
bester Homöopathie Packungsbeilagen
Tradition auf jede Flasche Homöopathie
drauf geschrieben kann Safran Globuli
C30 enthalten muss aber nicht
und liebes Landesamt für Natur Umwelt
und Verbraucherschutz NRW ist natürlich
alles nur Satire wir sind uns fast
sicher dass wir überhaupt keine
gekauften Globuli hier reingemacht haben
aber wir laden Sie herzlich ein uns das
Gegenteil zu beweisen
Tatjana wie geht's dir ja gut ich habe
noch eine Nebenwirkung für Safran
gefunden und zwar
Sehnenscheidenentzündung das müssen wir
unbedingt aufschreiben vielen Dank
Tatjana Gertz
Leute Globuli
selbst wenn man sie ernst nimmt kann man
sie nicht ernst nehmen das war's für
diese Woche beim Viking X Robert habe
kann jetzt schon mal anfangen zu
schwitzen nächste Woche sprechen wir
über Atomkraft bis dahin stellen wir uns
noch schön ein paar Flaschen Homöopathie
ins oberste Regal bis der Saft reinkickt
tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Homöopathie
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt auch in den Geschmacksrichtungen
Tollkirsche Banane und Annika Ananas
Freunde der Sonne das war meising x die
Show die erste Folge der neuen Staffel
der Rest kommt ab jetzt jeden Sonntag 22
Uhr auf ZDFneo oder auch schon ab 18 Uhr
online in der ZDF Mediathek wo ihr
natürlich auch alle Sendungen
nachschauen könnt die ihr bisher
verpasst habt meistens ist ja eine recht
neue Fernsehsendung und jedem Anfang
wohnt viel Arbeit inner ich meine war ja
auch nicht von Anfang an so wie es jetzt
kennt hier haben wir uns auch lange
darauf hingearbeitet und genauso haben
wir jetzt sehr viel Arbeit in die
Entwicklung von weißing X gesteckt und
ich hoffe ihr seht das und euch gefällt
das wollte ich euch nur mitteilen aber
nicht nur das denn bald geht es hier
endlich wieder ganz normal weiter mit
mylab ich habe richtig Bock ich hoffe
ihr freut euch auch wir sind gerade
schon ganz fleißig am Arbeiten an der
nächsten Wahlerfolge die bald kommt zu
einem kontroversen Thema mehr verrate
ich doch nicht wir sehen uns also bald
sowohl hier als auch bei meising X in
der ZDF Mediathek bis dahin bleibt
sicher